I saw you in New York City and we had
like kind of a nice exchange it was
really nice I saw you and then someone
took a picture of us and I just put it
up and said like this is my TV crush and
true no ok well wait a minute why'd you
have to qualify it like that so you
liked me when I was a lot younger
boyfriend now he's goofy things happen
to boyfriends you know now it's very
nice that's there was nice of you to say
that was nice for you to say they're
really back in the day you'd see me on
TV and think oh I like the cut of his
jib I love a weirdo you love a weirdo
love a widow I don't like where this is
going at all lack of sexual you're
really helping me out today
what I'm here for yeah my crushes were
like Jim Carrey and I mean what Smith's
not weirdo he's just but there was Hugh
Grant oh you really I was on Hanks yeah
Gump that's a weight of all time all the
time Hanks is too like you want that you
like the Forrest Gump time I love a man
who's got an analogy yeah my mom always
always used to say life was like a box
of chocolates I never know what you're
gonna get yeah very nice all right let's
say you just like
really an analogy would get you that's
what you like you are a man with an
analogy smart widow yeah bad well I got
half that